PRIYANKA VERGADIA: If you are
ingesting large amount of data
for analysis or
looking to simplify
the development of event
driven applications,
then you need to check
out Cloud Pub/Sub.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the last couple episodes,
we learned about Cloud Pub/Sub
through Cat-Out's asynchronous
order processing website.
We saw how Pub/Sub helps manage
the interactions between order,
packaging, shipping, and
notification services.
In today's episode, let's
build a Cloud Pub/Sub system
for Cat-Out.
As seen in the last episode
for Cat-Out's application,
the whole system will comprise
of three topics corresponding
to order, packaging,
and shipping service
for the sake of understanding.
Let's only consider the order
service sending messages
to packaging and
notification service
and build that
part of the system.
Feel free to extend this further
and build the whole flow.
All right, so we will have
a publisher application,
Order Service, which sends a
simple message, Order Received.
This message gets sent to two
subscribers-- the packaging
service and the
notification service, which
process the message.
And then these services
process and send the message
forward to their
topics and subscribers
to complete the order flow
and process to order fully.
OK, so now that we know
what we are building,
we are going to build
this in four steps.
Let's start with
step one where we
will create the Cloud Pub/Sub
topic for the order service
and the two subscriptions for
packaging and notification
service.
If you are new to Google
Cloud, create a free account
by navigating to
cloud.google.com/free
and following the
instructions there.
Then navigate to the
console and create or use
an existing project.
Make note of the project ID.
Now, let's navigate
to the Cloud Pub/Sub
subsection of the console
and click on Create a Topic.
Let's call this
topic order_topic.
Our order service,
which is our publisher,
will send messages
to this topic.
Then scroll down
on the Create Topic
and click on Create
Subscription.
Let's name the first
subscription as package_sub.
Leave the rest as
default, which will
create a pool subscription.
We use the same
procedure to create
another subscription attached
to the order topic called
notification sub.
At this point, your
Cloud Pub/Sub environment
is ready with the order topic
and the two subscriptions.
Now, we are onto
step two where we
will create a service account
that the applications use
for authentication and set
up Cloud IAM permissions.
Navigate to Service Account
Section of the console
and click Create Service
Account, enter a service
account name, such as Pub/Sub
System, and click Create.
For this example,
the service account
needs publishing and
subscribing permissions.
So we use the select a
[? rule ?] dropdown to add
the Cloud Pub/Sub Publisher
and Cloud Pub/Sub Subscriber
[? rule. ?] Click Continue.
And we do not need to grant user
access to this service account.
Then create key.
This key is used by
the Client Library
to access the Cloud Pub/Sub API.
Select JSON and click Create.
The key is sent to
the Downloads Folder.
For the purpose of this demo,
we can leave it there and rename
the key file to key.JSON.
Now, the next step
is to start the three
independent applications.
One, publisher, which
is our order service,
and two subscribers, which are
our packaging and notification
service.
For this step, we need the
Google Cloud SDK installed.
If you don't have it, today's
the day to download it.
If you're not already
in the Pub/Sub project
on Google Cloud SDK, then
set the project using
G Cloud Config set project.
List the topics to
see the order topic
we created from the console
and list subscriptions
to see the packaging and
notifications subscriptions.
If you don't have Python,
this would be a great point
to install Python and set
up virtual environment using
the steps in the
description below.
Create a folder where you want
to download the sample Python
files for this demo.
cd into it and
download the code.
Now, open three new terminals.
One for our order publisher
and two for our subscribers.
In these terminals, create
a Python virtual environment
and activate it.
Upgrade the Google Cloud
Pub/Sub in all three terminals
and associate the JSON key with
the service account created
earlier.
Now set up an
environment variable
with our current project ID.
We use the G Cloud command to
determine currently selected
project ID and set it
as the project variable.
Verify that the project variable
is set to our current project
ID.
cd into the directory
with sample code
and get into our
publisher file, pub.py.
Change the message from hello
world to order received.
Now, we are ready
to send messages.
Let's start our
packaging subscriber now,
which is Listening and
our order publisher.
Our order application sent
an order received message
with a message ID
while being unaware
of any existing subscriptions.
The packaging
subscriber application
receives the order received
message and prints it
and sends an acknowledgment
to Cloud Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub receives
this acknowledgment,
which indicates that the message
has been processed successfully
and does not need to be sent
to the packaging subscriber.
Cloud Pub/Sub then
removes the message
from that subscriber backlog.
Now, let's start the
notification subscriber.
And as soon as it is started,
it receives the message
published by the order topic.
The difference here is
that this subscriber
isn't started until after the
publisher has sent the message
to the topic and subscriptions.
If the notification service was
called directly from the order
service, then the
message would either
have to wait a long
time or time out
since the service
was not available.
Cloud Pub/Sub
manages this process
by effectively saving
the message for the order
notification subscription.
Today, we built a simple
Cloud Pub/Sub system
and learned how
it sends messages
from a publisher
to a subscriber.
At this point, you
should be able to build
a simple application
with Cloud Pub/Sub.
In the upcoming videos, we will
cover more important details
and choices you will need to
make when building a real world
application.
That's all for today
on Pub/Sub Made Easy.
Join us next time to check out
a deep dive into publishers.
If you like this video and would
like to see more such content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]